[Music]
videogames have influenced our culture
for decades the industry was built not
only by video game creators but also by
standout players in this series we'll
introduce you to some of the early
pioneers that brought gaming to life
this is 8-bit legacy a curious history
of video games being a kid in the 90s
men spending most of your quarters
trying to beat your friends in Street
Fighter the gaming community was filled
with memorable players but one kid
seemed to eclipse them all the legendary
homo o'hara one of the greatest video
game players who ever lived
[Music]
Tamura Hira was this towering figure in
Street Fighter 2
[Music]
guy that legendary that's kind of guy
you want to aspire me so why did the
champion disappear in 1991 arcades went
through a renaissance
with the release of Street Fighter 2 the
game re-energized the coin op business
drawing people away from their home
consoles and back to the arcades up
until then arcade winners were
determined by the highest score but with
Street Fighter 2 players dueled each
other in one-on-one competitions the
fierce matches and cutthroat rivalries
made the game into a bona fide sporting
event turning champions into legends and
a group of all-stars was forming in
sun-baked
southern california to get this story
started we first need to understand that
Street Fighter is a lot more than a
bunch of button mashing and who better
to explain the complexities of the game
then legendary players Jeff Shafer and
Mike Watson what Street Fighter is
really is a chess game they have six
different buttons that you can push and
whether you're standing or crouching the
buns are different and so you have so
much diversity of different punches and
kicks in a fighting game each character
has their own specific moves those
specific moves can be used in
combinations so there's so many
different variations available in the
game based on whatever character I'm
playing I know what distance that
characters weekend so it's all about
forming your game plan around staying at
that distance to win the game this is
the bread and butter of becoming
exceptional at any game that's Street
Fighter and if you haven't guessed it
yet Mike and Jeff are really good at
Street Fighter 2
I became the best player in Orange
County and then eventually I got banned
from playing because it was a foregone
conclusion that I was gonna win
I would beat everybody there was no one
I ran into that I didn't beat you know I
was a little kid just shooting my mouth
off all the time but that was part of my
strategy actually we always played to
win the whole crowd was thinking like
wow Jeff's on his own level you know no
one could touch me
I was eating everybody for lunch and
that's when I met Tim O'Hara he was
about 13 years old probably weighed
about 90 pounds and was 5 feet tall I
mean he was just so like a kid he's a
smaller guy so it wasn't intimidating
anything but man he played lights-out no
mistakes
it's just his play just amazing he's a
gaming savant
you know I must have spent over $20 in
quarters to beat him one game and I
never beat in one game I can't win one
game off the guy he's very much like
Michael Jordan or Tiger Woods they don't
need to talk crap they already know
they're the best he was hands down the
number one player at the time I was kind
of dumbfounded but it was like tolmol me
Jeff and then fourth place is way down
here and in 1994 the three participated
in a super tournament to find out who
was the best player of all time
there was a big super tournament in
NorCal that all of us went to it was
like the biggest battle royale ever in
the history of Street Fighter at that
time we're finally gonna find out right
in Southern California better than this
group here
it was literally shoulder-to-shoulder
people packed in like sardines and you
can probably guess what happened Tomo
won at all but then something unexpected
happened the world's best Street Fighter
2 player completely disappeared
he just quit that was it he never played
street fighter again after that
I felt a little empty I guess he was my
competition he was always the one that
would beat me he just finally walked off
into the sunset
[Music]
questions haunted the gaming community
where is Tomo where is the champion
everybody asks about him for years his
name rung out through the arcades in
Southern California everyone wanted to
find Tomo and play against him but they
never got that opportunity the original
gaming savant was gone so at this point
you're probably asking yourself what
became of the legendary Tomo Hira this
is my life now getting balls out of the
tree for the neighbors kids my name is
Tomo Akira I used to play Street Fighter
a long long time ago I was known as the
first champion a street fighter and the
feeling was just incredible I think
people were a little bit surprised by me
leaving kind of suddenly because I had
such a passion for it but eventually it
went from yes I want oh my god I can't
believe it - okay good I didn't I didn't
lose today so now that I have to be
upset tonight and that's when I fell out
of it
when we became adults right you don't
have the eight hours a day to put into
becoming like he was when he was a kid
he accomplished what he wanted he left
on top and we played one final turn him
in and he won so he kind of walked out
on a high note when something is done I
think he should realize it face it and
let it go so now my passion is family I
have twin kids that are two years old
and as soon as they're old enough I will
hand them a gaming pad and see what they
can do that's my life now and if I had
to turn the clock back and do it all
over again
I would not change a thing finding the
master sword in Zelda bouncing on a
Goomba in Mario honing your skills in a
duck hunt all things you probably did as
a kid with your first Nintendo system
for most of us playing games was a
pastime but for one lucky man this
wasn't some hobby it was his job
[Music]
1981 was a year of new frontiers in the
u.s. a new decade of technology and pop
culture was approaching making it a
promising land for booming Japanese
companies America had said hello to a
kitty a few years earlier but it was a
gorilla that stole the attention of the
new generation Donkey Kong was
Nintendo's first big breakthrough in the
Western arcade scene the game helped the
Japanese company climb its way up to
America eventually establishing a new
headquarter in Seattle Washington to
bolster their heads and this is the
story of one of their first employees
who is soon to become a gaming legend no
[Music]
this is Howard Phillips this is Howard
Phillips gaming jacket this is Howard
Phillips original 1989 Gameboy and this
is how Howard started working at
Nintendo kind of embarrassing I started
at Nintendo in 1981 it was really just
the five or six of us I was the shipping
warehouse manager my role was to bring
in all of the arcade games and unload
them and record all the serial numbers
and then pack them up for shipment it
doesn't sound like the greatest gig in
the world but working in the warehouse
came with one pretty big perk I could
play all the games whenever a new game
came in I could open it up and plug it
in and play it but playing games could
never be a full-time career or could it
Nintendo of America was run by this man
mr. Minoru Arakawa the company was
looking to break into the US market but
needed a little advice being Japanese
are very very attentive to the customer
and the customer was king I was their
kind of gateway into the u.s. zeitgeist
and all of what players really wanted to
play
whyyou Howard who knows why out of the
few people working with a company the
time that I
got kind of select as being one of the
more true voices I think it was just my
enthusiasm for play you know I'm a
players player I love to play games I
love to play at everything in 1985
Nintendo was ready to move out from the
arcade and into the living room mr.
Arakawa said to me what do you think are
the best games and I played them all I
said mr. Arakawa these are the best 15
games everybody will love these games
and so the game master was born Howard
Phillips also known as mr. Nintendo it's
his job to test every Nintendo game that
comes out what is a Game Master it was
really just a focus on what it means
when a player meets a game it's that
connection we were really looking for
someone to represent the gamer and to
speak directly to the gamer and Howard
really fit the bill he was like a
grown-up but he was still like a kid
gave you the impression more of a
character than a business person I think
the connection that I had with players
was that shared love of just gaming and
then their mom or dad would show up and
they would say but you know they're not
educational or whatever the the negative
association was that they wanted to put
with videogames in their child it may be
the most addictive toy in history
Nintendo videogames is it turning their
brains to mush shame on people that
produce that trash it's child abuse in
my judgment it was saddening to me that
that's how parents perceived their kids
joy as something that was maybe a
negative video games had a bad rep but
Howard could see the positive effects
the games had on kids it was a shared
love of the experience of discovering
something new or being really really
frustrated at something but just trying
and being patient and persistent
which is learning and the players wanted
to learn more more information more
tricks more tips and the game master was
there to deliver Tendo power your direct
connection to the pros for better play
video mastery for ordering information
my role was to make sure that every
single bit of information in that
hundred and thirty two pages each month
was accurate and spoke in a way that the
players wanted to understand and know
about but that wasn't the only role
Howard played when we were setting up
all the columns and an antenna power we
thought it would be great to include a
comic strip
Howard nester is just a cartoon that
describes child player who's always
trying to get past the next level in a
game and Howard is the game master who
knows everything about the games who can
provide some tips and Howard is you
that's me
dear Howard Phillips I am 12 years old
and your biggest fan my friends and I
read Nintendo Power who were the best in
your business your biggest fan with a
capital B by the notoriety of being Game
Master it really was crazy I would be
pumping gas at the gas station I would
be buying potato chips at the
supermarket or I'd be at a movie and
kids would come up to me and their
parents would come up to me and you know
and say oh you're the guy the guy who
was able to turn his passion for
videogames into a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity so Howard what was the best
part about being game master it was
really fun to fulfill people's dreams
you know and to shake the hand of some
little kid and asked them about their
favorite game and make them feel
validated and like they're smart and
cool so it was really fun
over
this might look like your typical
Western background but it's actually an
abandoned set of a video game the
Western was easy to accomplish here in
New Mexico we have the sets we have the
Cowboys we have the horses doing
everything we need including a great
villain Mad Dog McCree
there had never been a live-action
interactive video arcade game until that
dog came along
[Music]
the year was 1990 the dawn of a new age
of video games was about to begin
arcades had small but powerful rivals in
the living room the smallest the game
boy born in 1989 the scariest the home
console Sega 16-bit Genesis and
Nintendo's Super NES now anyone could
play high-end video games anywhere they
wanted our cade makers had to step up
and utilize their main advantage more
storage space that could hold hours of
video footage instead of
computer-generated graphics they used
live action live dialogue and live
actors the type of production values
that console games couldn't touch which
brings us back to where we started New
Mexico a place where a one-of-a-kind
experiment changed the video game
industry forever the props from that
first live-action game still remain in a
dusty warehouse outside Albuquerque I'm
Dave Roberts and I was director on Mad
Dog McCree it was our first entry into
video games these are the fake dynamite
sticks the makers of Mad Dog weren't
always in the business of making video
games they actually got their start
making police training simulators we
shot things that police would encounter
during their day they put it up on a big
screen and a police officer would walk
into the room he would have a pistol
that had had a laser put into it
he would respond to whatever was
happening on the screen once we knew how
to do that it made it a little easier to
do Maddog McCree my name is Robert
greevey and I was the CEO of American
Laser games this is the aha moment
actually looking at this picture I
realized that there was a potential to
turn this simulator into a video game
so that became Mad Dog Mad Dog McCree
the team now had the technology to make
a videogame but what they needed was a
story being located in New Mexico the
Wild West was an obvious choice and they
didn't have to go too far to find their
stars
[Music]
my name is Russ Dillon and I played Mad
Dog retreat I lived in New Mexico all my
life I was born and raised here on this
ranch I've been out here 60 years we
start shooting that nobody who Mad Dog
was or who was gonna be nabob greevey
decided I would make a good Mad Dog
obviously not for my looks probably was
because I could quick draw
yeah that's pretty quick in those days
finding a Mad Dog who could quick draw
was easy but transforming a blond-haired
blue-eyed Rancher into a
rough-and-tumble outlaw from the Wild
West that's a different story I guess
the most time-consuming part was the
makeup and the hair stuff and that hair
guy's a mess if I'd sweat you know we're
doing this and being black stuff roll
roll down my forehead when I saw him at
first dressed as Mad Dog I had no clue
it was my husband it was kind of like
looking at somebody else I was dressed
in the bugger thing black and that
horrid orange scarf it looks almost like
a carnival thing but I guess that became
the trademark of Mad Dog was that orange
scarf
the plot of Mad Dog McCree goes
something like this a gang of Outlaws
has laid claim to a small-town
kidnapping the mayor and his daughter
the players job is to kill the members
of the gang and eventually Mad Dog
himself freeing the town from terror
because players competed against live
actors in the game
the biggest challenge was accounting for
unpredictability the crew had to shoot
each scene in a way that allowed for
multiple outcomes of the same situation
we've got four people in the shot who
does a player shoot first oh my he
shoots number one first well what have
we shot number four first well we've got
to film that too one scene alone I'm
probably for different people I'm one of
the guy jumps out in the street and
tries to shoot you and then as you're
walking up the street to the saloon me
and they all come out fighting
[Music]
it was pretty corny you know but yeah
there's always a in a special place for
Mad Dog because because of what I was
and what it became
we didn't know if the game would be a
success we didn't know if the product
would work or not I mean it was
on-the-job training for all of us it's
hard to see the light shining so bright
it really exploded instantly in
popularity worldwide because nobody had
ever seen anything like it you've had
you can hardly get near again because it
was just so popular
[Music]
you better I really appreciate just how
much that we accomplished back 20 years
ago I never really thought the mad dog
would have a legacy but its iconic and
that it really sort of represented this
moment of time when video gaming went
from pong and pac-man to Grand Theft
Auto you know I think it was a wonderful
stepping stone for the industry